and in our business profile tonight a
two-generation passing of the torch in
the yoshida family
as margo yashida takes the hell from her
grandfather who built this tech giant
i know it will always be the focus for
corporation
to make profits but here
[Music]
so have you decided
what america says we can go wherever we
want
just say where
we i'm your bodyguard
so where do you want to go
let's just stop it up and then
we'll see
what's this open it
[Music]
interesting
welcome back everyone it's charlie this
is going to be my new marvel wolverine
deleted scene video
in new mcu wolverine stuff the director
of the logan movie was recently doing a
big watch along he talked a lot about
this yellow costume deleted scene
because he's the one that actually
filmed it he went on to talk about the
new mcu version of wolverine
they also explained what was going on
with that weapon x mr sinister post
credit scene if you wondered what that
was originally supposed to set up
big surprise it was actually for the
gambit movie so we'll break it all down
there's a whole bunch of easter eggs so
if you're new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get everything
we'll do an amazon giveaway all you have
to do to enter is be a subscriber
and let me know what you want them to do
with the new mcu wolverines yellow
costume
so starting with number five if you
don't know what's going on the director
of the logan movie james mangold was
recently doing a re-watch for the logan
movie and talking a lot about the
history of the wolverine character
he's also the director that filmed the
wolverine movie back in 2013
so out of any director he spent more
time with hugh jackman working on the
wolverine character developing him
so he's also the one that filmed this
deleted scene with the yellow costume
naturally everyone was asking him about
hugh jackman wearing it what's gonna
happen with the new mcu version of
wolverine so thankfully he had a lot to
say about that just explaining what was
going on with all this and what's going
to be happening in the future with
wolverine inside the mcu
so in this deleted scene wolverine and
mariko have just defeated her
grandfather silver samurai who has
stolen wolverine's healing factor
his adamantium claws had been severed
during the fight somehow he had gotten
his hands on a
ton of adamantium so his entire silver
samurai suit had a bunch of adamantium
weaponry
i remember there being all kinds of
questions about wolverine's bone claws
and him getting him adamantium back
after this movie came out so many years
ago
but after this is all over he and yukio
are headed back to north america when
she boards the plane with a special
parting gift
from marico like she used her tech
conglomerate company that she'd just
take it over from her grandfather
and all that extra adamantium that they
had to create a special costume
armor for wolverine as a way of thanking
him like giving him a special suit of
samurai
armor to represent his otter but it's
his yellow comic book
costume so he opens the box and is
delightfully curious about it not really
sure what to think
he doesn't hate the idea of the costume
he just raises his eyebrow
as yukio smiles like [ __ ] is about to go
down in the next movie
but number four you all remember what
happened after this is the next movie
was x-men days of future past they had
that post-credit scene that sort of set
up trask with professor x and magneto
telling him about this big threat that
was coming with the sentinels
in all of wolverine's scenes during that
movie after this point in the timeline
pretty much took place in that
post-apocalyptic future
so there's this giant time jump in the
beginning of days of future past
so you never actually get to see him
wear the yellow comic book costume
the way he explained that yellow costume
is that part of the reason why you don't
see wolverine wear it in this movie and
why they deleted this alternate ending
scene is because
this version of hugh jackman's wolverine
just aggressively hated promoting
himself in any kind of fanfare
in three you also probably remember it's
a big callback to the original x-men
movie where he makes a joke about them
wearing the matching black uniforms
asking if they actually step outside in
broad daylight where people can see them
in these costumes you actually go
outside in these things
what would you prefer yellow spandex
so it's not just the idea that hugh
jackman's wolverine hates wearing
costumes
is that brian singer and the producers
at the time they were making this first
x-men movie back in 2000 were deathly
afraid of being comic booky
and doing classic color uniforms in fact
kevin feige told the story about this
about how people
fought him too thin nail he tried to
tell them just do the comic books
because they'd have lots of questions
about how to figure out scenes how to
get through character problems when they
were filming the movie kevin feige
himself was a producer this is a picture
of him on the set of that movie
but he was relatively low level working
at fox he was a producer on the film but
he was only an associate producer so he
didn't really have any power
so usually he said that he would stand
in rooms during meetings with the
producers
and every once in a while he would get a
chance to give his input but usually
people wouldn't listen to him at that
point
it was until he became president of
marvel studios and he started calling
the shots that you really start to see
his creative shine through in the movies
since brian singer banned comic books
from the set but hugh jackman
wanted some comic books to study up on
the character he just wanted some
insight even though they were going with
a slightly different version of the
wolverine character
kevin feige actually had to sneak
wolverine and x-men comic books to hugh
jackman in his trailer on the set of
that movie
how hilarious is that kevin feige
defying the orders of brian singer
sneaking comic books so they can make
the movie better but later on when they
were actually filming this yellow
costume
scene james mangold said that hugh
jackman never screen tested
in the costume itself they just made it
as a prop for the movie and used it for
this funny moment this alternate ending
but in the logan movie when he takes
x-23s comic books that tell the stories
of their x-men adventures
he appears in a version of the yellow
costume it's not the original yellow
costume
because they had to change it for some
licensing weird issues with marvel
studios because
at the time marvel didn't have control
of the x-men and there were some rules
about what the x-men movies could use
for marvel comics
but when wolverine picks up her comic
books and starts flipping through the
pages
he claims that they embellish the truth
and take everything to extremes like yes
we all went on these adventures but
things didn't go down
exactly this way mostly omitting all the
really bad stuff that happened to them
like the comics were turning them into
the saturday morning cartoon versions of
the x-men which is also meant to be a
reference to x-men the animated series
from the 90s
all those episodes are actually on
disney plus right now too
there's been talk of them doing some
sort of revival in the future
but because of the missing time period
between this movie and the
post-apocalyptic future in days of
future past i think it's safe to assume
that at some point
the logan wolverine character within the
universe would have actually
tried on the yellow suit because it's
not yellow spandex it's actual real
armor
so too when james mangold says that the
next version of wolverine will
definitely be wearing the yellow costume
he's obviously talking about the new mcu
version of wolverine that marvel will
eventually cast
they haven't announced an actor yet
because it's still really early and
because their first major solo x-men
reboot movie is
years away i don't think they're gonna
actually lock someone down for at least
a couple years i've already done a bunch
of videos about the weapon x easter eggs
inside the mcu already and the wolverine
deleted scenes that kevin feige tried to
work into the mcu
there was an x-men deleted scene in the
original iron man post credit scene when
nick fury is telling iron man about the
avengers
kevin feige also said when they got to
captain america the first avenger movie
because they showed world war ii during
that they wanted to include
wolverine in a flashback scene when he's
saving the howling commandos so it would
have been a much younger version of
james hallett
wolverine before he'd actually gotten
his adamantium claws so
clearly there's a grand history of
weapon x being set up in all these
movies and in present day you have the
weapons plus program with thunderbolt
ross in the incredible hulk movie
in the upcoming falcon and winter
soldier episodes which are going to deal
with the weapons plus program
and it should go without saying but the
mcu version of wolverine's yellow
costume would also be a complete
redesign too
this yellow costume is a good
representation for what it's going to
look like because it's the only
real wolverine comic book costume in any
movie right now
the number one that mr sinister post
credit scene with the weapon x program
was actually supposed to be for the
channing tatum
gambit movie was supposed to set that up
mr sinister was going to be the main
villain of that movie
if you're not a big comic book reader
gambit and mr sinister actually go way
back in the comics
when he was younger gambit joined the
thieves guild and mr sinister hired them
to steal the weapon x diaries that the
scientists used while trying to turn
logan into the wolverine so gambit
breaks into the weapon x facility
just as wolverine is in the process of
escaping so gambit and wolverine cross
paths back then
he steals the weapon x research diaries
but decides they're too dangerous to
give to mr sinister so he burns them
so when you're watching mr sinister's
team come in and steal all this data
genetic samples for wolverine that would
have been a core plot element during the
channing tatum gambit movie
which kind of died when disney bought
the x-men and fantastic four characters
back so currently the gambit movie does
not exist
inside the mcu they'll also do a new
version of mr sinister in the mcu
eventually too
originally he was actually going to show
up in the new mutants post credit scene
before they stole him for the gambit
movie
the new mutants movie that will
hopefully be able to see this august
but hopefully that explains what's going
on with this yellow costume why they
made it for this movie why it wound up
being a deleted scene this alternate
ending it's still one of the coolest
marvel deleted scenes ever so let me
know in the comments what do you want
them to do with wolverine's yellow
costume
inside the mcu when they eventually do
debut their new
version of wolverine congratulations
zane martinez you're the giveaway winner
from my last big marvel video please
email me on the about page of my channel
so i can get your details
everyone click here for my brand new
marvel ghost rider movie video
and click here for that brand new new
mutants trailer and x-men
mcu breakdown thank you so much for
watching everyone stay safe i'll see you
guys tonight
[Music]
you